oui notre invité politique ce matin
c'est annie genevard bonjour bonjour
beaucoup d'être avec nous au député du
doubs présidente du conseil national des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bojan fabrice vce à redon
change du groupe et brach les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france que vous
connaissez bien bien sûr annie genevard
on commence par la crise sanitaire
emmanuel macron s'est donc exprimé hier
soir à l'issue du conseil européen
longue intervention un finalement sur
cette crise sanitaire sur la question
des vaccins mais aussi du confinement il
dit qu'il a eu raison de ne pas confiné
en janvier et il a défendu sa stratégie
est ce que vous êtes d'accord il a eu
raison
moi j'ai toujours considéré qu'il valait
mieux tout faire pour éviter un recond
finement compte tenu des difficultés que
ça posait pour les élèves dans les
écoles pour les entreprises pour les
commerces
donc chaque fois qu'on pouvait éviter le
confinement je pensais que c'était
préférable
alors évidemment là où l'épidémie flambe
il faut sans doute adapter les choses on
a toujours été favorable nous à une
régionalisation à des questions peut pas
confiné de la même on peut pas réagir la
même façon partout en france
donc quel est l'endroit où l'épidémie
est contenue il n'y a pas lieu
évidemment de durcir les choses là où ça
flambe et là où c'est hors de contrôle
assez bien pour vous coiffer leurs
ovaires de morges et sur la question du
reste une question c'était une bonne
décision politique est ce que c'était
une bonne décision sanitaires alors
sur le plan sanitaire vous savez cette
épidémie et les terribles parce que elle
est imprévisible
moi je vois chez moi on a toujours été
sur un plateau de contamination
et on a failli être dans la liste des
départements où ça allait reconfirmer et
puis finalement non parce que d'un jour
à l'autre sa baisse mais ça peut ré
augmenter donc c'est très imprévisible
c'est pour ça qu'il faut une certaine
agilité il faut une certaine je dirais
mobilité dans l'est dans la réaction
la vérité est que au fond ce qui nous
dit encore comme il ya un an c'est le
risque de saturation hospitaliers et
hospitalières
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi pendant
un an on n'a pas pu équiper des délits
avec de nouveaux respirateur il ya un
élément nouveau à prendre en compte tout
de même c'est l'épuisement des soignants
là pour la première fois on a des
signaux convergents d' alerte sur un
épuisement d'aidés soignants et ça c'est
probablement un phénomène nouveau parce
qu'il ya un an les célébrer on les
applaudissaient il était au combat et là
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment l'esprit les
a un peu
est ce qu'on les a un peu oublié ses 512
refaire hier françois baroin il disait
ça serait bien de refaire une campagne
de communication est exactement vous
avez je suis absolument d'accord parce
que on a tendance à considérer que leur
travail fait partie des choses normales
que leur dévouement est une chose
acquise
en réalité ils sont les soldats du front
est et je pense qu'il faudrait vraiment
un organe considération par rapport à
emmanuel macron ses déclarations d'hier
on n'a pas été assez fou en gros idiot
on n'a pas été assez fou moi je dis on
n'a pas été assez audacieux on a bien vu
que cette gestion de la crise sanitaire
elle s'est fait d'une façon sûre
administré avec des deux le principe de
précaution ont multiplié à tous les
étages trop sur la question des vaccins
trop il ya des choses qui sont mises en
place dans les pays étrangers depuis
fort longtemps
je pense aux auto test moi j'étais au
royaume uni à noël à noël on pratiquait
les autotests et ça se passait très bien
aujourd'hui on n'est toujours pas en
capacité de mettre à disposition des
français des autotests des tests
salivaires
au motif qu' il ne serait pas certain à
100%
voilà cet excès de prudence est ce cet
esprit trop précautionneux qui nous
empêche d'aller loin moi je dirais pas
manque de folie on n'a pas besoin de
folie de la part de nos dirigeants
on a besoin d'audace on a besoin du
résultat on a besoin d'engagement serez
soignants juste un instant nous allions
il ya quelques semaines président du
conseil départemental de seine saint
denis qui étaient ici un des
départements les plus touchés par le
coït qui nous disaient depuis un an sur
le système de santé les effectifs les
moyens
rien n'a réellement été fait est ce que
dans un département comme le vôtre
ledoux parliez du plateau du retour aux
particuliers est ce que les choses ont
évolué disons qu il ya une gestion qui
est piloté à la fois par la rs et par le
préfet en lien avec les élus
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui existe
depuis début ça fonctionne plutôt bien
dans le dialogue mais on veut ce qu'il
n'a pas changé en revanche c'est que on
est toujours en attente du matériel
qu'il faut on a été en attente des
masques on est en attente du gel on a
été en attente des tests on a été en
attente
on est en attente des vaccins des
aiguilles
voilà donc on manque toujours de quelque
chose pour affronter cette crise et
c'est absolument terrible on organise
les maires ont été admirables pour
organiser des centres d'accès à sion et
sauf qu'on peut pas vaccinés ou très peu
on parle des écoles ça aussi cette année
les écoles olivier verront hier il a dit
qu'il fallait tout faire pour maintenir
les écoles ouvertes quitte à avoir un
protocole sanitaire en force et françois
baroin qui est je le rappelle le
président de l'association des maires de
france lui dit que le sujet des écoles
il doit être posée que c'est pas un
sujet tabou qu'est ce que vous dites non
c'est pas un sujet tabou d'ailleurs chez
moi dans ma circonscription on est
obligé de fermer un collège
hier le préfet m'a alerté m'a averti de
la fermeture d'un collège parce qu'il y
avait quelques dizaines de cas et tout
ça pouvait ça pouvait flambée donc ici
ou là on va jusqu'à la fermeture quand
les choses échappent au contrôle
moi je trouvais recèle ont franchi rage
et vos livres et veyran de dire qu'il
faut maintenir les écoles ouvertes la
limite coûte que coûte
oui alors bien sûr il faut essayer de
maintenir les écoles ouvertes parce que
des élèves privés d'école ce sont des
répercussions sur un sur des difficultés
d'apprentissage de façon durable dans
une scolarité mais
c'est la question de la vaccination des
enseignants par exemple il faut vacciner
les enseignants dès maintenant pour vous
ah oui dès maintenant
oui bien sûr c'est un public prioritaire
pour moi c'est un public prioritaire si
tant est qu'on veut et maintenir les
écoles ouvertes alors on vaccine les
enseignants il faut aussi pouvoir et
s'attache une condition pour vous il
faut que la vaccination des enseignantes
débute maintenant
ça peut être un objectif ça doit être un
objectif en particulier dans les zones
exposées
je comprends pas non plus pourquoi on me
délice pas de façon régionales on a des
outils de modélisation des airs les
médecins avaient 10 mars ce sera très
difficile
et en effet marc c'est très difficile
pourquoi on me délice pas aussi
régionalement
est ce que on a des indications
épidémique on est capable de dire ce que
ça va donner dans dans quinze jours dans
trois semaines
moi je trouve qu'on n'utilise pas
suffisamment cet outil de modélisation
qui a fait ses preuves mais enfin une
fine et vous savez on a beau tourner la
question dans tous les sens tant qu'on
n'aura pas les vaccins dernier mot sur
cette question des écoles est ce qu'il
faut par exemple avancé les vacances
scolaires c'est ce que propose notamment
valérie pécresse
je trouve que c'était une bonne idée
c'est astucieux c'est astucieux parce
que on prive pas les les
les étudiants les lycéens de et
collégiens de d'enseignement
on anticipe les vacances c'est pas trop
pénalisant moi je trouve c'est s était
fait pour les parents comme si c'est pas
plus compliqué qu'un jour avant que
quinze jours après en fin pas forcément
plus compliqué tout cela veut dire qu'on
les avances non les rallonges pas pour
vous american oui pour moi j'avais
compris que c'était un décalage oui
j'avais pas compris que c'était une
extension moi je trouve que c'est assez
astucieux ça mérite ça mérite autre
chose qu'une réponse du ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui semble-t-il
n'a pas cherché à explorer l'idée on va
passer à un autre sujet qui concerne
particulièrement les républicains bien
sûr c'est cette annonce de candidature
de xavier bertrand s'est enfin sur quel
polichinelle mais c'est officiel je
serai candidat à la présidentielle il a
dit ça dans l'hebdomadaire le point
est-ce que vous avez été surpris par
cette annonce de candidature par le
calendrier par la manière dont ça s'est
fait oui et non parce que non parce
qu'on savait qu'il serait candidat
ils sont savait que il n'était pas
favorable à se plier à la primaire donc
de ce point de vue là les choses ne sont
pas surprenantes
ce qui est inattendu c'est qu'ils le
fassent d'une façon aussi je dirais
médiatisé presque solennelle avec des
éléments programmatiques ça c'était un
peu inattendu alors est ce que c'est une
bonne chose pour la droite de votre
point de vue écoutez je me pose pas
exactement les choses de cette façon
moi je suis convaincu que la droite doit
trouver celui ou celle qui sera le plus
rassembleur à chacun de ces candidats
parce qu'il n'aura pas cas à chacun de
ces candidats de faire la démonstration
qu'il est le plus rassembleur si c'est
xavier bertrand c'est xavier bertrand
mais il doit faire la démonstration
qu'il est le plus rassembleur si ce
n'est pas xavier bertrand il y aura
d'autres candidats qui devront faire
leurs preuves en la matière donc et
comment vous l'avez prix vous aurez
public un set face à cette annonce de
candidature est ce que vous l'avez pris
un peu comme un coup de pression de la
part de xavier bertrand
alors moi je je je
crois qu'il faut vraiment se défier des
déclarations intempestives en la matière
pourquoi parce que une fois que ce
candidat aura fait ses preuves d'une
façon ou d'une autre tout le monde devra
se rassembler derrière lui car comme l'a
dit gérard larcher hier et il a
absolument raison
s'il n'y a pas qu'un seul candidat pour
la droite nous ne serons pas au deuxième
tour donc que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités vous avez peur de ça est
ce que est ce que vous imaginez que la
droite peut survivre
cet avis est à ce péril c'est un péril
mortel ça si nous sommes sommes plus de
deux candidats avec nous ne sommes pas
au deuxième tour pour la seconde fois
c'est un péril mortel pour notre
formation politique mais elles me
charles ella iv jacques à lui un peu au
pied du mur xavier bertrand ça veut dire
qu'on doit vous vous rassemblez derrière
moi soit il y aura de candidats non il
ne nous met pas au pied du mur parce que
le calendrier des républicains n'a pas
véritablement changé
c'est à l'automne que les choses vont
véritablement se décanter deux cas de
figure
premier cas de figure entre maintenant
et l'automne un candidats se détachent
nettement alors ils se détachent
nettement dans l'opinion publique dans
la classe politique dans les sondages
enfin vous voyez bien quand il ya une
dynamique qui s'installe autour d'un
candidat on le sait on le sent on le
voit on le mesure c'est ce que christian
jacob un candidat naturel un candidat
qui s'impose naturellement
ça c'est pour moi le cas de figure idéal
parce que pour moi la primaire c'est une
machine à se donner des claques et il
est et va avoir lieu non si un candidat
se détache naturellement elle n'a pas
besoin d'avoir lieu soit autre cas de
figure aucun ne se détache et là il
faudra bien trouver un système de
départage
comme le dit
gérard larcher mais moi ce que j'espère
c'est qu'un candidat se détachent
nettement
parce que là est ce qu'il n'est pas en
train de prendre une longueur d'avancé
à lui d'en faire l'épreuve à lui d'en
faire la démonstration
ce que je vois dans sa déclaration c'est
que il donne des éléments
programmatiques son projet montre qu'il
a été réceptif aux projets des
républicains puisqu'on retrouve beaucoup
d'éléments du projet des républicains
donc ça avant d'abriter la question du
travail laquelle sur delà des
territoires du coup je repose ma
question est est ce que même sur le
projet sur le fond est ce que vous
pouvez vous opposer à ce que dit xavier
bertrand
est-ce que du coup ça devient pas un peu
superflu d'avoir un autre candidat est
ce que il vous met pas au pied du mur
non mais on est un parti démocratique ne
pas empêcher des candidats et il y en a
de valeur de vouloir se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle
on ne peut pas imaginer que de auch dès
aujourd'hui les choses soient clarifiées
de cette façon là ce avait cinq jours
vous montrer le système de départage
vous maintenez le calendrier à l'automne
pour vous de ça ne change absolument
rien sa déclaration de candidature
il faut nous nous sommes fixé un
calendrier il est il un t il a toujours
intégré la donnée de xavier bertrand
quitte un candidat de droite mais dont
on pensait qu'il attendrait les
régionales mais dont on pensait qu'il
attendrait les régionales il anticipe
parce que ma chacun est libre de porter
ses convictions l'essentiel est qu'on
soit tous réunis derrière celui elle est
où là où celle en tout cas la seule
personne qui en 2022 nous fera gagner ça
signifie annie genevard que les
républicains seraient prêts à se ranger
derrière quelqu'un qui n'est pas
derrière un candidat qui n'est pas chez
les républicains
les républicains sont prêts à se ranger
derrière la personne qui sera le mieux
les rassembler porter
leur valeur et nous faire gagner donc
voilà il faut alors faisons un peu de
politique fiction imaginons qu'à
l'automne à l'issue de votre système de
départage qui sait peut-être une
primaire en tout cas un vote c'est ce
que souhaite bruno retailleau ce soit un
autre candidat que vous aviez bertron
qui sortent de ce système de départage
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors vous
imaginez toutes sortes de scénarios nous
nous prenons les choses dans l'ordre il
faut les prendre comme ça laissons à la
première hypothèse la chance de
prospérer
c'est à dire qu'un candidat émerge
naturellement voilà est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'il ya d'autres candidats
par michel barnier le même jour que co
xavier bertrand lui il a dit qu'il était
prêt à mener la bataille présidentielle
est ce que lui par exemple ça serait un
bon candidat mais il fait partie des
candidats qui se sont mis sur les rangs
il ya des gens dans votre camp qui
amenait le retour de françois baroin qui
lui disent qu'il faut qu'il revienne
qu'il n'a pas d'ailleurs officiellement
annoncé qu'il ne serait pas candidat
est ce que vous croyez encore à une
candidat l'écouté tant que les choses ne
sont pas dites elles ne sont pas dites
il a laissé entendre à certains de
choses mais en effet il n'a pas dit
radicalement qu'il n'était pas candidat
donc tous et quand c'est encore une
hypothèse pour tous et candidat
potentiel supposé espérait il ya encore
une fois il y en a un que vous espérez
une enfin qu'une fois qu'ils se mettront
sur la ligne de départ on veut on y
verra plus clair pour l'instant il y a
un deux candidats déclarés sauf erreur
de ma part il y à bruno retailleau et il
y à graviers bertrand on suppose qu'il
peut y avoir valérie pécresse on entend
qu'il y aurait peut-être michel barnier
et pourquoi pas françois baroin donc
voilà une fois qu'ils seront alignés sur
la ligne de départ on y verra un petit
peu plus clair vous en avez encore
moissonnée lmnp je ne me suis pas je ne
me suis pas ranger derrière un candidat
encore je le ferai le moment venu
naturellement
je ne me déroberai pas mais j'ai trop vu
ce que donnait la logique des écuries
présidentielles
j'ai trop vu les désordres engendrés par
la primaire finalement la primaire c'est
une machine à claques qui joue sur la
différenciation voir l'opposition entre
les candidats ça je n'en veux plus
parce que la division au sein de notre
famille politique je bannis tout ce qui
divise notre famille politique
un dernier mot pour faire la transition
avec les régionales dont on va parler
les républicains soutiennent toujours
dire via bertrand dans l'autre france ah
oui bien sûr on va parler des régionales
justement selon un sondage 71 % des
français approuveraient un report des
régionales pour des raisons sanitaires
c'est un sondage obea pour france info
le figaro
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que les français ont pour première
préoccupation leur santé la crise
sanitaire
du reste ça occupe l'intégralité où la
quasi intégralité
sauf bonjour chez vous ce matin où nous
parlons d'autre chose de la crise
sanitaire donc évidemment ça les obsède
et dans ce contexte là les régionales
qui sont un scrutin qui a un petit peu
moins identifié que les municipales par
exemple pour les législatives où
fortiori la présidentielle donc il
considère que c'est peut-être pas de
première priorité à nous aux politiques
de bien leur dire qu' on ne peut pas
reporter indéfiniment des élections par
peur de les perdre parce qu'on sait très
bon c'est ça pour vous tuer l'exécutif
veut reporter ces élections c'est une
raison politique n'est pas une raison sa
des talents mais un fort soupçon je vais
vous dire pourquoi
d'abord parce que cette idée elle court
depuis juillet dernier je le sais
j'avais posé une question au
gouvernement parce que emmanuel macron
avait lancé un premier ballon d'essai en
disant on pourrait peut-être reporter
les régionales après la présidera la
présidentielle donc là il y avait une
bronca il était rentré dans la tranchée
on en avait plus entendu parler
à la faveur de la progression épidémique
les chiffres sont pas bons il retente
une sortie de trancher en disant tiens
on pourrait finalement peut-être quand
même reporter les régionales
expliquez-moi comment c'est risqué
d'aller exercer son devoir du citoyen
dans les conditions où le fera avec
toutes les précautions sanitaires comme
le disait
la sénatrice tout à l'heure alors que ça
ne serait pas dans le métro ou
supermarchés la démocratie c'est
important reporter les éléments c'est
donner le sentiment que la démocratie
est facultative elle ne l'est pas c'est
important les régionales et les
départementales sont un scrutin très
important pour la vie quotidienne des
français dont clairement la position des
républicains parce qu'on dit on n
imagine que vous allez être consultés
entre le chef cas christian jacob sera
consulté la position des républicains ça
sera pas de report ce quel que soit
l'avis du conseil scientifique dimanche
mais nous on ne voulait pas de clause de
revoyure on a voté une loi pour dire les
élections départementales et régionales
7 en juin
donc je souhaitais appliquée donc nous
souhaitons l'appliquer il ya une clause
de revoyure au 1er avril on va voir ce
que ça donne mais entre le 1er avril est
la fin du mois de juin
ça sera peut-être pas exactement la même
situation sanitaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle on voulait pas de la clause de
revoyure parce que la clause de revoyure
l etat un mois et demi presque deux mois
de la dudh la tenue du scrutin donc
forcément la situation est unique
reste que pendant la campagne électorale
donc la situation et leur a clairement
évolué ou alors ça veut dire que le
gouvernement a définitivement passer par
pertes et profits la sortie ou
l'amélioration de la crise sanitaire
ce qui serait un abus un aveu d'échec
total donc non on ne met pas la
démocratie en confinement
on ne reporte pas des élections parce
qu'on a peur de les perdre
on ne donne pas le sentiment que la
démocratie est facultatif dernière
question sur la zone avant de finir avec
l'actualité avec fabrice votre région la
région bourgogne franche comté c'est
l'une des principales cibles du
rassemblement national est ce que vous
êtes prête à un front républicain c'est
la situation impose on est prêt à faire
front derrière notre candidat gilles
platret qui a toutes les armes pour
faire campagne contre le front national
et contre la gestion socialiste de cette
région qui n'a pas brillé par son éclat
qui passe complètement sous les radars
qui n'a pas été une politique ambitieuse
et je compte vraiment sur surgit plâtre
et jarry fermiers et leurs équipes pour
redresser la barre du contrat
vous savez pas vraiment ma question est
ce que si le rassemblement national est
en mesure de l'emporter vous pourrez
vous pourriez faire alliance avec les
socialistes ou vous retirer pour
empêcher une victoire du rassemblement
je ne crois pas du tout que nous soyons
dans cette situation je ne crois pas du
tout je pense que la candidature de
marie du fait n'est pas faible jeu la
présidente sortante journée donc elle
sera bien présente
je pense que notre candidat a toutes les
armes pour être allé sur le front qui
efface sur le terrain occupé par le
front national c'est quelqu'un qui a
donné des gages en matière de sécurité
qui à des positionnements très clair et
qui montrera que le vote du front
national est une impasse et est une
supercherie est la dernière question
d'actualité qui sera certainement au
coeur de la campagne régionale et
nationale sur cette polémique autour des
réunions non mixtes racisées le
gouvernement a condamné avec des mots
très forts que tout il faire maintenant
organisé par les nationaux oui oui bien
sûr bien sûr c'est toute la question de
l'islamo gauchisme à l'université qui
est en train de compromettre gravement
la liberté académique et les savoirs
académiques à on voit bien que les les
indigéniste les essentialiste les
racialiste qui développe des théories
victimaire qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses
je rappelle que l'université c'est quand
même la matrice de la formation des
enseignants de notre pays donc c'est
l'enjeu et qu'on est complètement
considérable la réponse du gouvernement
est d'une faiblesse absolue parce que la
condamnation verbale ne suffit pas il
faut prendre des mesures
c'est quoi les mesures à bas les mesures
dans la moi je considère que
une année qu'un étudiant qui prône des
stages interdit aux blancs fait preuve
d'un racisme qu'il faut qu'on ait des
majeures le litre cette affaire doit
aller en justice il ya du racisme
caractérisé il faut lutter pied à pied
contre l'islamo gauchisme dans
l'université et pas se contenter de le
dénoncer verbalement comme ça veut dire
clairement vous demande au gouvernement
de porter plainte contre l'unef travers
par exemple
par exemple certains même prône la
dissolution ont dissous génération
identitaire ça pose la question de
savoir s'il faut dissoudre l'unef
et puis que la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur prennent des
mesures pour soutenir les courageux
professeur qui risque gros
lorsqu'il dénonce ces mouvements on l'a
vu à grenay là elle a été l'une des
premières à mettre le sujet sera tort
elle a été courageuse de le dire mais ça
suffit pas depuis qu'elle l'a dit elle
est très prudente parce qu'elle s'est
fait énormément attaquer il faut
maintenant que le gouvernement soit
derrière elle pour prendre des mesures
offensives
c'est un sujet est un enjeu majeur et
merci beaucoup merci à mme jeanne marre
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
fabrice on regarde la une de l'est
républicain coville 19 la lorraine en
sursis c'est à la une de votre journal
dans de nombreux journaux du groupe ebra
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous pas
ce titre au club d'états et à la
mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]